après les modèles les modèles en
fauteuil roulant celui qui pète de
prothèses prothèses auditives prothèse
de jambes ou présentant un vitiligo et
bien aujourd'hui on nous présente
Elizabeth borne la première ministre qui
a présenté le programme du gouvernement
des 100 prochains jours avec deux
projets de loi un consacré au plein
emploi et l'autre sur l'industrie verte
qui seront présentés d'ici l'été
nouvelle Barbie Barbie porteuse de
trisomie 21 avec des yeux plus en
amandes un visage un peu plus arrondi
elle porte elle porte la des baskets et
un collier particulier qui représente le
chromosome de la trisomie 21 pas de
grandes annonces mais un cap ce que nous
disons nous le faisons et nous
continuerons à avancer oui c'est du
cabotage effectivement c'est très
poussif madame la Première ministre a
parlé de 100 jours d'apaisement mais
sans jour d'apaisement ne suffiront pas
à apaiser 6 mois de colère aujourd'hui
la première préoccupation de nos
compatriotes c'est le pouvoir d'achat
dans les prochain mois nous allons
maintenir les boucliers sur les prix de
l'énergie et faire un point mi-juin sur
l'efficacité du trimestre anti-inflation
dans l'agenda aussi le projet de loi
pleine emploi sera présenté en juin avec
une réorganisation du service public
autour de France travail successeur
annoncé de Pôle emploi je pense qu'il
faut que avant de retourner voir le
président de la République au Premier
ministre il faut qu'on se voit entre
nous entre syndicats et patronat pour
essayer de dessiner les contours de la
Corse qu'il faut pas si vous voulez
c'est que on soit dans une contrainte ni
de temps je l'ai dit un laissant jour
j'y crois pas suite aux manifestations
lundi pour le premier anniversaire de la
réélection d'Emmanuel Macron a
manifestant a subi l'ablation d'un
testicule après un tir de LBD oui
les ministres sont désormais pistés par
les manifestants hier soir c'est la
secrétaire d'État chargée à l'écologie
chargée de l'écologie Bérangère kouyat
qui a dû annuler une réunion lors de son
déplacement en Charente-Maritime parce
que 80 personnes voulaient s'infiltrer
dans le lieu de la réunion il lui pose
d'abord une couronne sur la tête
puis le frappe
avant de le brûler
c'était lundi à Grenoble un peu plus tôt
c'est le Ministre de la Fonction
publique Stanislas Guérini qui avait dû
annuler sa visite à Castelnau-le-Lez
dans l'Hérault en raison de la présence
des manifestants lui promettant un
accueil sonore plus que mouvementé en
revanche la loi sur l'immigration est
repoussée à l'automne faute de majorité
il n'existe pas de majorité pour voter
un tel texte par ailleurs ça n'est pas
le moment de lancer un débat sur un
sujet qui pourrait diviser le pays on a
l'impression qu'elle nous annonce un
grand hibernement de 100 jours 100 jours
c'est son délai de préavis avant
licenciement apparemment mais elle ne va
rien faire
je suis personnellement partagé entre un
sentiment
d'en observant un sentiment
d'impuissance et aussi il faut le
reconnaître un peu de cafouillage je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la France c'est un
petit peu une un pays qui est au point
mort voilà c'est une voiture qui est au
point mort alors Emmanuel Macron fait
ronronner le moteur mais c'est un pays
qui n'avance pas la voiture n'avance pas
de son côté Marine Le Pen dénonce il n'y
a plus de gouvernement à la tête de la
France seulement une administration des
affaires courantes Jean-Luc Mélenchon
n'est pas moins sévère puisqu'il déclare
quand un gouvernement ne peut plus
gouverner même pour des décisions
stupides fautes de majorité c'est qu'il
doit s'en aller lui et c'est réformes
sous un soleil de plomb une chaleur
écrasante dans les rues de Séville
jusqu'à 39 degrés relevés en pleine
après-midi vague de chaleur
particulièrement précoce en ce mois
d'avril avec des températures largement
supérieures au normal de saison résultat
et la conséquence de la volonté du
gouvernement de porter un énième projet
qui allait régulariser des clandestins
les républicains le refusent il faut un
référendum si on veut enfin changer de
cap locaux et touriste en viennent tous
au même constaté